[Music]  [Music]  November 8th at 7:30 in the morning this  town started to burn down within three  hours was going house to tell you what  it's not easy no no but we're a lobby  it's not just that I lost my house it's  not that I lost my memories my entire  way of life is completely gone as hard  as it is to say I don't see the town  coming back a lot of people have left  the hospitals gone now much of school is  gone I thought it would get easier as  time went on but it's actually getting  harder at the end of the day I have  nowhere to go  paradise water may not be drinkable for  up to three years we have to make them  pay for everything because it's going to  happen again if you don't don't we have  a responsibility just stop if it's gonna  be in areas that are not defensible this  is my home this is where I wanna be  I love that town and I'm not gonna bail  on it  Oh guys made it through made it guys  you